weil ich es wieder eure mal wann und wie
kommst du einen freund wie schmeckt und
welcher cocktail darf in unserem kopf
der reihe nicht fehlen natürlich der
white russian aus the big lebowski sehr
der den wert den der wind dem tut immer
trinkt die grammatik war noch nie meine
stärke aber es ist natürlich was immer
ich mache dem white russian der der den
ich mache den branchen den der tod immer
tricky muss sagen ich habe schon zwei
gemacht falls ihr den film entwicklung
nicht kennt das ist nicht schlimm der
ist auch aus 1998 der wahrheit damals
auch gar nicht so ein großer film der
wurde hat über die jahre zu seinem
kultfilm und jeder kennt sie jeder kennt
ihn gut und jeder kennt den weit waschen
und den fahrer darauf probieren weil ich
unbedingt wissen wollte und die beiden
cockpits ist die tat löste auch nicht
sehr lang wir brauchen café likör von
einer marke wie ganz ohne wichtig ist
und wodka und sahen eigentlich braucht
man so ein kurzes glas was glaube ich
kenn das glas genannt wird habe ich
nicht ich komme aus dem norden und haben
große last aber ich glaube das sollte
ausschließlich also denn gut mit seinen
weit raschen sehr entspannt er macht ein
paar die publicis account seinen reihen
das kann man natürlich auch so machen
wir machen es ein bisschen perfekt und
zuerst frauen
[Musik]
ein t shirt sei wodka das ist kaffee
likör habe ich gelernt habe ich probiert
zweieinhalb chili paprika habe die ganze
zeit überlegt worüber kann ich reden
wenn ich über the big lebowski reden
möchte aber der film einfach so ein
entspannter action sogar zehn menschen
jetzt gehen wir nach einem schuss sahne
nicht ganz kurz ein bisschen schüttelt
damit er ein bisschen texte wird jetzt
führen wir die zahlen sich das
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir ganz leichten zu wow
the dance chicago ist es so krass dass
man in der bahn so viel geld für diese
drinks immer bezahlt und sie sind so
schnell gemacht und ihr dass man in
skandinavien also zb dänemark und so da
gehen die leute nicht so viel ausmachen
es sich eher mal zuhause schönes wegen
kommt er auch von da weil wir wissen wie
man sich zu hause schön macht mir
wirklich also möbel sind am schönsten in
skandinavien dänemark schweden und so da
die wissen wie man möbel macht auf jeden
fall wissen wir dass man lieber drinks
hause trinken so das ist natürlich
wieder eine vermutung und kein vermutet
die ideen bleiben zu hause ist und nun
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage warum macht man
es auch so kurze videos und wie schmeckt
der branche aus the big lebowski das
irgendwie sollte man ja morgens trinken
den cocktail den sollte man morgens
drehen falls ihr euch um eure mama jeden
morgen eis kaffee trinkt das ist kein
eiscafé rabin als café im hals brennt
den kosmopoliten kann mich besser
wie kann eine bewertung machen jetzt
haben wir die drei cocktails gemachten
mir habt am besten der cosmopolitan auf
6 in dem sinne geschmeckt auf platz zwei
kommt der night session auf platz 3
eigentlich auf gackern platz kommt james
bond wirklich wieder und natürlich kann
man auch alle cocktails immer
alkoholfrei machen wenn man doch unter
18 ist oder einfach gar keinen alkohol
trinkt das will ich auch viele leute
damit kann alkohol mögen das ist auch in
ordnung ich gehöre definitiv nicht dazu
die folgen hat daran einen daumen nach
oben hilft mir sehr weit mit dem kanal
falls sie noch weitere videos sehen
heute von mir und nicht in vergessenheit
geraten wollte sich noch existiere
abonnieren und glocke aktivieren und
dann ziehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
und dann muss auch wieder zwei kopien
eines gesagt die ganze zeit
wahrscheinlich in den kommentaren
willkommen den ball an kommt alles kommt
alles was ich muss das video ein
bisschen länger strecken wie geht's euch
lasst uns mal reden hier und damit sage
ich tschüss und bis zum nächsten mal und
[Musik]